Tạo sáng nay ngày 20, 2 năm 2020,
Ishrain đã phát động một đòn tấn công phụ đồng nhằm vào Iran với mức tiêu lại bỏ các mối đe dọa đối với những nước Ishrain.
Này sau đó, bà quan chức nghĩ sắp nhận với trên thông giảng Mỹ đang tính hành các cuộc không kích nhằm vào Iran trong đó một quan chức một tại đây khu phải làm một đòn tấn công nhỏ.
Há tình suitor sẽ lời một quan chức nghĩ trong biết các cuộc không kích của Washington đang được sửa hai sáng xong với chiến dịch của Ishrain.
Một ngần tin Ishrain khẳng định, chiến dịch đã được lươi gái hoạch trong nhiều tháng với sự phối hợp chả chế giữa theo Aviv và Washington và thêm với độc được quy định từ vài tần trước.
Chuyến thông nghiên cứu Iran cho biết nhiều tiêu tiêu lộn phang lên tại trụ đô tên Iran và các thình phụ Ishphahan, Pio Mở, Karai, Kơ Mân Xà, Khó đây bất cao tại nhiều phí của Kụ Tên Iran, một số quần tin cho biết lãnh tụ tụ cao Iran đại giá trụ ali khá mê này đã được chiến tự định bạn còn.
Bây phía Ishrain, chiến khủng nước này từ bố tình trạm hình cấp trên tần Quốc, Bölisal dữ báo khả năng Iran đáp trả văng tiếp bị mai không người lãnh và tin lợn đã đạo.
Chua độ Ishrain chỉ hoa hệ tống khỏi vào độc chú độc trên tần Quốc, giữa cầu mươi rất là người dân tự gần lươi chủ ở.
Dễn đến hôm nay được đánh giá có thể mở giá một con bữa đầu mời dữ Ishrain, Mỹ và Iran trong một cạnh của dịch trong đông bốn đã phức tạp bệnh điều đến mong ăn đi.
Hả năng đáp trả của Iran và lĩnh của các được độc đông bình trong cuộc đất cố yên là chiến của các cuộc đình qua sẽ là những tổ tiên cho tỉ hình mỗi lộ là thang trong kế giả tối.
Dỡ, tụi tả nền, hả viểu dõi ạ và tất cả.
Só phía rời.